this is sal here with famous indycar
dryer driver smiling when i said famous
j.r hildebrand and
since you're here i thought i would ask
a question that that's always been on my
mind yeah we have a picture here of of
the of the indianapolis motor speedway
yeah
and and i've always wondered you know
how you it seems like turning is a very
important part of that and it's
absolutely an important part of it of
the reason we'll get fixated on the car
going straight but the turning part
turns part where a lot of the skill
comes into it and i've always wondered
you know what is what is optimal do you
all try to minimize your distance and
kind of take the turn as as quickly as
or as in as short of a distance as
possible by kind of really hugging the
hugging the corner by going like that or
but when you do that you have to kind of
you have to turn more there's more
g-forces there's more uh kind of
centripetal force that you that that
your tires have to deal with the human
has to deal with uh versus versus taking
the outside where you have to cover more
distance
but the the centripetal acceleration the
g forces aren't going to be as dramatic
so so how do you think about that well
every track ends up being a little bit
different but when we take indianapolis
here as the example if you're all the
way on the inside and it's like the 800
meter runner's kind of path it's the
shortest distance you can kind of get
from point a to point b the lap is the
same every time so it doesn't actually
depend on you running a specific
distance or not
for us in this example the car actually
just won't do that you know if you think
about being all the way on the inside
being all the way inside through the
corner and then exiting all the way on
the inside it's having to do the most
work
to follow that path
and in indianapolis we're approaching
turn one at upwards of 240 miles per
hour wow and that turn one is not it's
it's hardly banked it looks quite flat
in person so
as opposed to you know nascar running at
uh talladega or daytona these big giant
super speedways the car is having to do
quite a lot of work to get through the
corner here
so how do you take the outside or is it
well so then you know you look at that
and i think if you if you noted sort of
the radius that we like if you if you
drew a full circle out of the out of
each of those arcs let's do that so
let's say this is the shortest distance
path this is kind of a circle that looks
something like
my best let me scroll over a little bit
so that we can see a little bit better
so this would be a circle
like this if you were to keep that arc
right going it would be a circle that
looks something like this so that's a
pretty that's a pretty small circle it's
a smaller circle
yeah and for the larger one the circle
would look something like
it looks something like this
right so you have a larger radius a
larger turning radius so you would have
to have less centripetal acceleration
inward acceleration and less fewer g
forces on this outside one right larger
the circle is in a different way to look
at it if you looked at the car trying to
just go around these two different
circles and it's going to be going the
same speed on either one it's doing a
lot less work to get around this outside
circle and therefore the speed that you
could carry around that then sort of
goes up you know the car has a limited
ability to stick to the racetrack so i
think putting that up definitely makes
it but that's an important point at
least in indianapolis you're full
throttle the entire way yeah so when
you're saying i mean obviously if you
hit the brakes the car could
do what you know a very small that's a
good point yeah but but you're you're a
full throttle i mean you're not you're
not gonna have any chance if you at all
let off the guy that's right when you
qualified in indianapolis you've got to
put in four laps four of your best laps
of the season of your career in
indianapolis to qualify um and that you
are absolutely flat chat the whole area
on the racetrack there's no lifting
there's no braking and so that's why
you're saying car just wouldn't do that
if you're going all out the car just
wouldn't even be able to make this this
exactly so from a driver that's a good
point from the driver's perspective you
have to stay flat out if you're going to
go fast if you're going to set a lap
time that's relevant you have to be able
to stay flat out and so at that point
then you're searching for the line
around the racetrack that you can do
that most efficiently right and so then
in this example
moving that
increasing that radius by going from the
from our green circle out to the purple
circle
does that rather effectively i see or
going from the purple to the green back
like so you're saying like this
well yeah and so then to find the actual
optimal line what we end up doing is
starting out on the outside of the track
then bending the car into the inside of
the track
and going back to the outside of the
track really using all of the road
that's available to us right so that's
interesting so you know when i posed the
question it was kind of like i was
my brain was just looking at these two
circles but right you realize there's a
bigger circle that you could fit here
that there's an arc like this and this
would be you know if you imagine this
would be a part of a circle that's way
huger than even that even that purple
circle that we're drawing yeah
the center of that circle is like here
or something right so you have a lot
less centripetal acceleration that you
have to place inward acceleration that
you have to place on the car exactly and
therefore the car is able to carry
a massively increased level of speed
through the corner and that that's
that's really what we're looking for you
know you consider i think it's it's a
very interesting
when i think about what i'm doing as the
driver i don't think i really
am consciously thinking that much about
the the mathematics that go into finding
this optimal racing line you sort of
instinctually just gravitate towards
what the car feels like it wants to do
but when we look at it from this
perspective you've got the car going
down the straightaway here it's at at
240 miles per hour that's almost as fast
as the car is gonna go so it's just this
sort of terminal velocity uh the drag of
the air hitting the car won't allow it
to go the engine is giving all the power
it can yeah you're out that's just
offsetting the drag of the so you can't
accelerate exactly it's almost like
you're hitting a wall of air at that
point you're not going to be able to
accelerate any faster and so what you're
really trying to do is you're trying to
in order to set that fastest lap time
which ends up equating to
the like highest average speed around
the lap that's what's the lowest number
in terms of a lap time perspective
you're trying to get the car to most
efficiently
get through the corners so that you can
allow it to accelerate down the
straights right as much as you can
you're sort of getting it to diverge
from this
intended course that is going on here as
efficiently as you can and so by
creating the largest radius around the
corner
that's how we end up finding that
optimal line that's fascinating